- I wanna be in this person's armpit.
(easy rock music)
- I cannot believe we're
smelling shirts that you've worn.
- Ooh girl, smell that.
- Why do you sniff that hard though?
- I expect a lumberjack
who's like 38 to wear this.
- It smells straight-up
like my grandfather's
deodorant.
- Yeah.
- This is a grown-ass man,
- Yeah, yeah.
- who's not afraid to
smell a little feminine.
This is nice.
- This smells sexy.
- Ooh, this one smells good.
- You get one, I get the other.
If my boyfriend was wearing this,
I would just like, hang out
in his armpit and be like...
- It smells beachy.
- I love you.
- It smells like the smell
of when a guy puts on a new shirt after...
- After what, Michelle?
- Yeah (laughing).
- Ooh.
- She went for it.
- I like this one as
well, this might be Axe.
- This might be Axe.
- I think this is Axe.
- And I'm okay with it.
- This reminds me of a
very specific boyfriend
and I can't put a name on who it is.
But, it's like, bringing me
back to a college relationship.
Is that weird?
- It just smells like a freshly
cleaned gym locker room.
- Yeah.
- High-end, high-end.
- It's a one-swipe kind of guy.
He doesn't even like (bleep).
Just like one swipe, out the door.
- This one is little bit
more feminine, I think.
- Definitely.
- It is slightly girly, which
is probably why I like it.
'Cause I like girly deodorants way more.
- I think I would get
with this one, I like it.
- This is for sure a simple guy.
- But like in a good
way, not in a bad way.
- It smells international to me.
- Sexy.
- Yeah.
- I'm really torn, but
I'm gonna go with B.
- I'm gonna go with B as well.
- (bell dings) (together)
Oh, Gillette? What?
- I wouldn't mind smelling
this on a daily basis.
(bell dings)
I am a cheap person (laughing).
- I like Degree, cool.
- Gillette, that's the one that
smells like aftershave yeah.
- Don't tell me I picked Speed Stick.
Robert!
I am not a Speed Stick woman.
- Degree, I knew it.
- Oh.
Gillette? Really?
- Joanie, you picked Gillette?
- I'm just glad it wasn't Axe.
I was really nervous.
- [Voiceover] Your ex-boyfriend was Axe.
- It was Axe.
- Fresh.
[Voiceover] Really, your
ex-boyfriend was Axe.
- Is Axe?
- Eeww!
That's why you broke up with
him 'cause he wears Axe.
- I'm not mad at Axe, I'm not mad at Axe.
- Axe.
- You weren't mad at
either, that was choice
- I know.
- If your grandfather hadn't
worn it you wouldn't exist.
- Oh, that's funny.
- And my grandfather
literally wears Old Spice.
- Let's get one thing clear right now.
If anybody comes up to me
smelling like any of these deodorants,
they're good.
- They're good.